[Music]
hey good afternoon everybody
thanks for coming to our talk for
joining us here my name is Fernando
Sanchez I'm a customer engineer with
Google cloud in New York City and here
with me is Sebastian Morgan yourself
howdy
yes so like Fernando mentioned we're
both customer engineers out of Google
and NYC and we're here to talk about the
wonders of lamp and the modernization
thereof so our talk is called plow defy
lamp so proverbial show of hands who's
running lamp based site in production we
know what lamp is that's awesome who's
ranked uber natives in production less
people less people difficult one who's
running lamp on kubernetes in production
that's all right
good well I hope we have something for
all of you today
yeah so so like I said like we said this
talk is about running lamp inside the
cloud so it's it's all about modernizing
IT so if you think about like all of the
different challenges that we've had in
the past in terms of running something
in production depending on where you are
in history of different solutions to
those problems so if this is the
modernization talk right
let's figure out how we can go back in
time kind of talk about what's going on
and try to figure out what we can do
today to make things a little bit easier
to do so for the purposes there we go
for the purposes of this presentation my
colleague here Fernando is going to play
the role of the CTO of Vandelay
industries where my CTO had actually
does have a CTO hat focuses
custom-ordered I'm going to be a DevOps
engineer I don't get a hat because the
DevOps engineers are very low on the
totem pole so Vandelay industries anyone
anyone heard of them before just out of
curiosity I was a couple people over
there that are laughing at the jerk that
we've got but yeah they specialize in
import/export and orchid
texture they work very prominent in the
90s and as a result we're going to go
kind of back in time you take a look at
that sort of thing but thanks to Google
cloud nowadays they have a very modern
super high performance IT stack that
happens to be very focused on lamb like
I said before if this if this is all
about modernization we can't talk about
modern IT stacks without talking about
sort of where we came from so now that
he Fernando is gonna take on the role of
the CTO I'm gonna take on the role of
the DevOps guy we're going to go back in
time I wish we had sort of led that
fading music and whatnot but I don't
wanna put audio in the presentation to
keep things simpler so hey it's the late
90s picture this in your head we've got
a handful of different websites right
this is what the web looked like back
then you might recognize the top left
one over there it was beta we like
putting the beta tag on a lot of
different pieces of software and in this
particular era websites like these were
starting to come up because businesses
started to realize that having a digital
presence made a lot of sense you can't
just be a business that is entirely in
the brick and mortar space without
having something online that you can
redirect customers to or or do something
like that
the term ecommerce is starting to get
kind of popular there's a couple
different websites that you can go to to
purchase goods or to take a look at
inventories or maybe set up things with
these schedule things and whatnot and of
course there's different websites to go
make your own website for your dog or
family or whatnot but at this point in
time the big trend is everybody's got to
have digital presence of course everyone
is thinking about I got to have a
digital presence I gotta have a
different digital presence and you know
who noticed that we had evidential
presence here at Vandelay industries to
see our wonderful CTO we needed a tow
presence we need to be in the Internet
everybody's in the Internet it looks
like this internet thing is taking off
so I think bundle I should be enduring
today we need to get on this web thing
and then establish a database so
engineering team how are you gonna help
me get into this web thing that's a good
question
this is a new kind of situation to be in
but web things web things web things
okay what is this web thing look like
well if I'm gonna have this web thing
I'm gonna need a server of some sort
this giant boxy thing would work fairly
well it's very typical of the era I'm
gonna need some sort of web server
software so obviously if you gotta have
a web server you gotta have hardware you
gotta have software with everything also
we should probably create some HTML
files which means by we I mean me I'm
gonna go code static HTML files and hope
that works and of course we need an
animated gif because it's the late 90s
and anybody who doesn't have an animated
gif isn't being hip and that is that
escape we need an animated good I will
make sure we have several animated gifts
especially talking about being under
construction and the like let's go on so
I had a little bit of a thing and this
is what the modern web stack looks like
to me so we've got a big UNIX box
somewhere we've got this thing called
Apache which is brand new it's
open-source though I think you'll like
it
and we've got all of those static files
that I mentioned before they're not
super complicated half a dozen lines of
code and we can get this up and running
okay let's get to it
okay cool I'm so I built a server I
deployed this everything's fantastic
okay so we're gonna build pages for
import expert and I could take you yeah
three three websites super easy
import-export architecture that's all we
need right because the only thing let's
see if you think this web thing is
probably just a phase anyway don't worry
about it so okay time goes on so now
it's the early 2000s the big thing that
we've got going on here is the web who
knew that it would be this successful
you've got tons of companies that are
embracing this new digital platform
establishing a digital presence and
having a digital brand I mean it's crazy
the website that we set up has been
getting a fair amount of traffic as it
turns out people are really interested
in import/export and architecture
rhein-main tonight and as a result we
want to make sure that we keep this
thing up and running and doing that
thing I've been diligently updating
these static HTML files by hand in a
variety of different editors and every
time you request a new page because now
we have more than one in
port page and more than one export page
in more than one architecture panel the
addictive April's you love the
architecture pages but there's a lot of
stuff that I have to work on to get this
up and running but you know times they
are a-changin yeah little stuff is
happening the internet down absolutely
so this is what's on our minds now now
we've got cell phones they're becoming a
little bit more ubiquitous we have
digital content that it's being sold and
also downloaded potentially illegally we
also have the internet becoming this
major factor in the success of
businesses no longer is it the case that
a business can just exist without having
some sort of digital presence the
business has to exist and a fair amount
of their revenue actually comes from
having some sort of digital presence
online so that people can go and you
know buy goods and services and the like
vandalize where Abby sees working
Grady's gonna a lot of toffee who did a
lot of business on the internet but
obviously ten goes by and I feel like
you guys are having some challenges I'm
the engineer if I'm honest we are
actually having a few challenges one of
the things that we're running into is
that single server as wonderful as it is
to work on and I absolutely love the
environment and whatnot there are it
doesn't stay up the way that I would
like it to stay up occasionally it
crashes and I have to go fix things also
I have to replace the occasional part
that breaks on top of that I got to make
sure that the content that you want
delivered is coded and shipped and then
sent out to a bunch of different people
so that's uh it's a little bit
challenging and I think we need more
features I think that thing of do you
having to edit all the HTML files my
hand that's and you ended scene that's
not very practical so I think we need to
generate the content dynamically near
the system so that the website is there
the structure is there we just add the
content and remove the content and we
just you don't have to edit the HTML
files and the other thing is that walks
as niceties I see that these Google guys
are like using commodity servers and
they're being very successful maybe we
should be using commodity servers and I
keep this thing on virtual servers
server apparently you can create servers
inside servers and you can copy them and
move them around and then you can use
the hardware better so I think I think
in my CTO vision that we need to
implement a content management system
and it needs to be virtualized
engineering team yeah
how can you help that we better okay
content management system got to be
virtualized alright let's figure out how
to do that so what does a modern IT
stack look like what is this
CMS thing that I have to build well it's
still a website so I still going to need
a web server I'm still gonna need a
database I'm gonna have to come up with
some CMS software but now I'm gonna have
to hire a couple people okay that we've
been super successful on our founder art
Vandelay has been just absolutely
pivotal and attracting the type of high
caliber individuals that we want to have
in our organization so as a result I got
to hire some ops folk because now I have
a bunch of different VMs that I have to
manage like for example the database VM
and right I have to manage the web
server VM and and whatnot also I'm gonna
need dev folk yep because you now we're
using an application that's going to try
to manage all of these dynamic websites
for me so I'm gonna have to hire those
people and also a VM what's it again the
virtual machine okay yeah I'm gonna have
to make sure that we've got something
that can actually manage that and wrap
that up nicely so what does this look
like in my head had a bit of a thing
this is what I've come up with so let's
see what you've got so modern web stack
well in you know 2000 so we've got lamp
by the way Linux Apache my sequel PHP
that's what it stands for for the same
Genie thing it's just an acronym yeah so
we've got Linux instead of Unix because
UNIX is on the way out and Linux is the
new hotness also it's cheap it's free
and it works just as well a little like
that
I'm saving people money Apache is still
actually in the running because Apaches
doing tons of stuff there they're
continuing to implement new features
they are the de facto web server
software that you can get also of my
sequel free database know about you'd
like that as well we're announcing for
the year for use in free speech both
actually which already Chrome
although they do have support services
so we can you know I'm gonna go plug
into them if we need additional support
whatnot and PHP is this secret softs
programming language that kind of wraps
everything together and generates those
dynamic websites for you by the way
we've got to count them two different
ways of doing that we've got Drupal and
WordPress okay so we can choose either
one of them
those are the applications that will
will actually generate these things and
what we can interact with and then over
here this will do your VM stuff all
right
KVM or Zen I got to do a little bit of
research to figure out which one's
better for our needs but yeah more
Shashank event
I can't there wasn't there something
else that did these things it's like a
vendor or something oh yeah well there's
this there's this crazy woman Diane
green or whatever she's starting this
company but I hear that they're kind of
expensive so I'm going to keep things
nice and free and open source so that's
what the modern web stack takes it look
like okay so you guys said chuse Indies
you guys said she some news and you see
that he said what other people are
choosing is it a very regional or
absolutely do you want to actually hold
on a second let's do some statistics on
here well I grabbed some statistics take
a look at this but this is all of the
websites that we're running on the
Internet
look at this big giant chunk once I
build a internet ronnie'll and one the
Internet's actually on land and of the
people that are actually using it
two-thirds of them have chosen either
word plus or Seesmic WordPress Joomla or
Drupal which means those two things that
I mentioned before pretty safe for CMS's
two out of three CMS's seen the world
are either word preserve RuPaul
absolutely looks like you guys bet for
the right horse
okay I'll love it although it so let's
go let's use this let's use this and
then this move on in time using these
things for how it's the year 2010 2010
cloud on our minds flowers everywhere by
ODEs clouds clouds I can't walk down the
street I can't open my email without
tons of people in trying to recruit me
with this interesting cloud thing I
can't go anywhere without hearing about
cloud cloud cloud cloudy cloudy cloud so
on our minds its cloud and then it looks
like this realization thing that we were
having what's working but we're also I
see you guys are having some challenges
with the current architecture right
after this is growing at vandalized real
with the progress that we make in in the
three pieces in import-export
contexture he's absolutely thrilled
business is going out but it looks like
actually we're eating our limits here
right we are if I'm honest we do have
some engineering challenges one of the
things that we've got is running my
sequel locally it doesn't scale I have
to go in and resize things it's not just
VMs I actually have to buy additional
hardware I got to make sure I have a
backlog of discs so that I can make sure
that they arrive at the data center at
the right time to make sure that we can
put them in servers rack and stack and
configure them and get them deployed and
everything in it also I got a I really
want to scale each component
independently not just at the VM size so
like different web tiers or at different
sizes the different VMs and whatnot but
the underlying hardware architecture so
later the network needs to go a little
bit different because the web front-end
needs to talk to the database back-end
and make sure that that pipe is nice and
fat so that everything can work also I
don't like getting paged I've been with
the company for a long time but I think
if you embrace their words of our
founder he talked about not wanting to
do too much time yeah and I don't want
to be on call anymore also deploying and
operating and maintaining these servers
I actually have a lot more work to do I
have to hire a bunch of people to do a
bunch of different things but I got to
maintain the hardware and I got to
maintain the virtual equivalent for that
hardware which is it's eating up a lot
of my yeah yeah I see I see I see I want
you guys focusing on what this company
does we're not we're not a hardware
company we're a company focused on
import/export and architecture so I want
you guys building software that does
just that whatever your company's doing
no truck were not operations the other
thing that I'm saying is that we're
having challenges every time we get more
and more demand and what I want is for
that thing to just scale up and down and
I would like just to pay for what we're
using I don't know what we're paying for
stuff that we're not using so I would
like things flow to scale and I would
like you guys to be focused on
operations I would like to be focusing
infrastructure I think we should be in
the cloud cloud we should be in the
cloud cloud cloud why are we not in the
cloud we need to be in the cloud I love
the cloud I even like the word cloud
cloud technical officer yeah yeah wait
to see I got yeah okay cloud
all right let me go have a bit of a
think - cloud cloud cloud okay if we're
gonna move to the cloud I'm gonna want
the cloud to provide a bunch of stuff
for me okay so if I think about what
this cloud thing is if I think about
what it provides
I got to pair it up with business needs
so what I need is first of all I need to
figure out how to use the cloud kind of
obvious but I need to figure out to do
that we developed a lot of in-house
expertise with KVM in Zen but they don't
quite apply because I have to learn a
GUI and there's api's and guys will do
that for you right not necessarily with
our specific infrastructure and the way
that it's configured so I'm not sure
they can put a button but it's difficult
oh so I heard about this term called
lift and shift it even rhymes it's gotta
be better as a result we really should
migrate our applications we've got those
three big apps we've got the import
workload the export workload and the
architecture workload so we want to get
those up to get them linked in and then
put them in the cloud and yet she okay I
like it yeah well hold on a second
though there's this thing called cloud
native I keep hearing about that yeah
stuff that's born in the cloud and it's
designed to like leverage things so I
should really figure out what what
that's all about
but in the meantime it's just lifted
shifted right let's move it let's go
wrong been times go by go by [ __ ] or
stuff to the cloud saying the cloud and
we're happy you don't have getting paid
to 3m now well know occasionally here
and there but for the most part not too
bad so what so we still have the VMS in
the cloud mm-hm and we're still handling
the databases in virtual machines in the
cloud so so I'm we doing that the whole
same thing but just in other people's
computers I see what you're saying yes
but but okay we don't have to worry
about the hardware components of things
right yeah we can just focus on clicking
a button getting capacity and I don't
have to worry about that guy that we
hired to
deal with just like all of the hardware
specific things we've retasked him and
now he's actually working in our DevOps
group merchandise like that pretty cool
I'm still concerned abut cuz you
mentioned cloud lady 10 years ago and I
am Not sure I keep hearing that I keep
hearing people about using the cloud but
liked in an elastic way in a demand way
so now I'm concerned like how we get the
most out of the cloud are we doing using
the cloud in the best way possible
engineering Tim well to be honest
probably not necessarily so what else
can we look into
let's go back to what I actually need
the cloud to do so what does this cloud
thing actually provide and what do I
need it to actually do how do I get the
most value out of this investment well
what what I need what we need and the
wonderful Vendela industries is the
liability scalability automation
standardization I need the thing to stay
up when I put it up hmm I need the thing
to scale so that it doesn't go down and
thus does not stay up I also need to
automate it because we don't we we only
have a handful of people and we've got a
lot of webpages now so I want to push a
button and have something work
standardization though I absolutely need
standardization the reason I need
standardization is we learned one
framework one infrastructure thing and
then it changed we went to another thing
we had to redo everything I don't want
to have to do that again I want to just
push a button and then have it work it's
a matter of fact I want no ops don't I'm
sorry what
no operation Falcon how I like that how
amazing would that be I mean imagine a
world where I could push a button and
the computers would run themselves I
like it so you guys would be focusing on
instead of operations and hardware and I
like it I like it
we should do that so do you think we
should look up that modernity stack with
today's tools maybe yeah all right so I
had a bit of a think okay and I think
I've come up with some interesting
interesting components I think you'll
like okay so let's look at it this is
what I think a present-day modern IT
stack is going to look like let's
leverage this thing called kubernetes
let's take advantage of better virtual
networks better virtual storage let's
leverage things like managed security
hosted monitoring and logging and a
boatload of automation is here's the
thing I don't want to have to power an
entire subsection of infrastructure just
to manage the rest of infrastructure
that I need to deploy I just want it to
work for me which is pretty darn cool
especially when you consider that
kubernetes does a lot of the work for us
it's kind of an interesting concept we
just have to containerize some
applications in here and there and I
think we should be good all right so we
have an idea I think we should work on
it we should probably get our lamp stack
and use all these things and see how it
looks okay so they're work all right
let's work on it so our lab solution so
now my colleague Fernando is going to
stop being the CTO of this wonderful
mountainous Evangeline industries and is
instead going to resume his role as a
Google customer engineer alongside
myself and we're going to talk about the
actual link solution that we came up for
for any industry that wants to take
advantage of all of the things that we
mentioned all the needs that we want and
get all of the benefits that we talked
about as well okay so we wanted to get
our lamp application so that she'd stay
the same because we have a lot of stuff
developed for vandala industries that
has been working on Drupal or WordPress
if we still want to do that but we want
to put that in containers we want to put
that in containers that it's immutable
so that we don't have to change it we
don't have to configure we keep it yeah
but we don't want to handle containers
we don't want to go from managing VMs to
managing containers so as much as we can
use a managed container service
somebody that handles the cluster for us
well that would be great
the other key piece for lamp is the
database that's what information is
right that's that's the core of
assistent spinal tap
if we can remove the operation space if
we can get some good sleep without
having to work in backups in keeping it
up in high availability and things like
that that would be great
so let's look at a managed version of my
sequel the other thing that lab has is
storage and storage has two functions
the first one is we're lab keeps state
that's what your repo machine would say
the configuration and that's where it
also would save some static content or
your images or your videos or anything
you so how about we get a cloud storage
solution and we plug it into the
into a solution into the into the rest
of the cluster the last piece that we
wanted is automation
how can we put all these together so
that we can create clusters with a
single click and have all the
configuration for our class status code
in repo somewhere so if somebody wants
to make changes to the cluster she
shouldn't have to touch the cluster
should shut that stick out and then
redeploy okay but the most important
thing to of all of these things on here
the thing that makes or breaks this
solution is kubernetes I mean like a lot
of the other stuff sure but this is the
this is like the absolute crucial
component that's to work it's it's I
think it's a good solution as well
so why calamitous ok kubernetes is kind
of interesting first of all it's a
standard so we write a manifest -
kubernetes it'll work on any kubernetes
offering that's out there it'll work on
any kubernetes environment that somebody
has provided the environment you know
works and whatnot
also it maintains our desired state
through failures meaning I don't have to
get paged kubernetes will take care of
restarting things so that reliability
component is just taken care of by the
automation that kubernetes ends up
providing also it provides scalability
they kind of go hand-in-hand
so if we're getting a massive you know
influx of traffic we can take advantage
of kubernetes scaling capabilities and
auto scaling capabilities like I know
Vandelay industries was SuperDuper
interested in that in the past
- to spin up more infrastructure and
consume it as needed
also it's relatively easy to program I
say relatively because yeah it has a
quirky sort of gamal syntax and whatnot
that you have to fiddle around with but
once you get it done all of your states
even really complex applications can
actually be mapped out inside of
kubernetes services there are some cons
though it's hard to manage the fact I'll
stand over here so you can people can
actually see it's hard to manage it's
it's a big distributed system with lots
of moving parts it's difficult to
upgrade because it's a large distributed
system with many moving parts it's very
difficult to scale for the same thing it
also requires other infrastructure
services to function meaning that like
you need a VM to put kubernetes in it
needs a computer to actually run the
code that powers the rest of the cluster
also
it prefers stateless applications not
applications that have state that need
to grab a bunch of stuff on the back end
but I think I can solve most of these
issues let's take a look at google
kubernetes engine otherwise known as gke
what's really great is we get all of the
same pros it's still a standard it still
maintains your desired state it still
provides scalability and reliability you
get a bonus that it's managed by
Google's legendary SRE team you can
actually go over there and and take a
look at them also but it still prefers
stateless applications so this solves
most of the issues that we have in terms
of managing our infrastructure is that
for that stateless part do you have any
I did the thing with legacy applications
is they were not written to be stateless
they were written to say state to some
sort of file system you have come files
and you have state files so if instead
of running a single server we want to
run an one hundred a thousand of
containers that suppose we're running
the same application they should be
sharing the stick and containers are
stiglitz
if you reboot a container the filesystem
in the container is gone that would mean
that if we put up a Drupal container we
configure it and we start putting stuff
in there and we rebooted it's gone so
how do we simulate how do we get legacy
software and make it believe that it's
running in legacy infrastructure we're
still we provide the advantages of
modern architectures so what we need to
do is basically clear a shared file
system and make all those containers
access that shared file system and make
it available to it for all of them to
read at the same time and for all them
to write at the same time so how do we
do that in kubernetes well that's
basically a filesystem bound that it's
read many write man is everyone familiar
with that so there are a number of
solutions that allows you to do that one
of them for example is a simple as NFS
an NFS could be an NFS server per NFS
could be any storage solution that
supports an NFS interface so that you
guys have your favorite storage vendors
that can have a huge system provided
super secure NFS and and you can connect
it to a cluster or you can use use they
own demand FS server by Google cloud
file store we will provide you with
storage managed by the legendary Google
a sorry sorry
theme so basically the other thing that
happens is that state it's for static
content and it's for configuration but
the way that many people are using lab
these days including Drupal is what it's
called head where's CMS but that means
is vandala industries at some point may
not like the way that Drupal and
WordPress look for the front end they
may just want to use Drupal because it's
a great content management system it's a
system that they can use for their users
to create content to edit content and
maybe instead of offering the UI for
troupe out the front end for Drupal and
WordPress maybe they want to use
something like the API for tuple on
WordPress put an API gateway in the
middle and then you stay favorite
technology to write the front-end
whether it's react Redux whether it's
angular when it's anything they want to
use so you get the best of both worlds
you guys you get your front-end your
frontier calls the API gateway the API
get this gets the content from Drupal
and out what that means is that storage
system that has the state has actually
way less stringent requirements right
that is that's that's not a key
component from your system because the
static content is probably hosted
somewhere else the react Redux is like
hitting the API gateway the API gateways
getting it from somewhere else
so what we're going to get in that
distributed storage system is just a
basic state basic configuration and hold
on a second so you're a Google customer
engineer you work in the retail space do
you have actual real world customers
that want to take advantage of something
like this it's not just
Vandelay industries but you actually
have real world customers that would be
interested in this yeah we import export
market texture and we actually have a
customer who has three words to that
that may be using this unfortunately
they couldn't make it to to the call
today but this has been live today the
headless CMS idea tuple is becoming is
getting a second life by being used as a
headless CMS and so that you get the
best of both worlds the front-end you
download your own front-end use an API
gateway and connect it to through policy
CMS so what's all this look like then in
detail what do we have here what we have
is many containers running our software
so software still processes the the
content that we developed for it
the years have the Apache and the PHP
pieces been running in containers and
containers running on GK that means that
they all to a scale on the map the
horizontal part of the scaler to scale
the teapot and then the cluster of the
scaling up to scale the nodes if we get
a peak in traffic the cluster scales up
and down as we want the static content
is created with with with basically a
file share and that file server is
mounted into kubernetes with with a read
many read many amount and then on the
left side or the left side for you we
have basically managed my sequel
database what that means is using the
cloud sequel service which is hit about
on garum on its database handled by
Google
we just need to program the backups we
just need to basically let go and that's
handled by somebody else and we pay for
what we use here are the scales we just
literally pay for forever we use it and
then in the bottom piece one of the
things that we wanted to do is not
having to basically clip through your
eyes and send many commands and take
weeks to deploy this thing we want a 12
to make this whole thing and in this
case we'll use terraform for that do you
want to discuss for example why would
you surf on for that well I mean as that
DevOps guy I like using whatever is
available out there and whatever the
specific customer might have familiarity
with so for example you can bring
anything that you want that provides
infrastructure as code functionality in
the industry terraform tends to be
pretty darn popular so as a result we
decided to write our solution using
terraform and a couple shell scripts
that actually like bootstrap the entire
environment terraform can be a little
bit difficult to get stood up in the
sense that you have to configure the
provider you also have to configure
different backends and so on and so
forth with different clouds however once
we get all of these things together
really you could use pretty much
anything that does infrastructure is
code
Google works a little bit differently in
the sense that we like partnering with
and we also like supporting a lot of
different open source technologies
absolutely so we want to make sure that
whatever you're already using in your
industry we support and it runs really
well on our platform but if you want
guaranteed compatibility and you want
sort of an SLO associated with things or
an SLA assasinated things you can use
something called deployment manager
which is our version of infrastructure
as code
so okay and that's it and what we have
also is a demo and for the demo we would
like to ask you for a favor if you guys
go to Cloudland org we decided to do two
things the first thing is get all the
code that we did for this and an open
subset so we basically put it all in the
web for you guys to use to inspire you
to clone a to to find some some quick in
there and open that open up some
requests for us this has been running
for a few days already and the way this
is running I wanted to show you this is
right on this it has been set up using
the terraform script so if you guys go
to our repo here you will it will take
you to get lab and you have all the code
here so you can go into the Drupal
WordPress and instead Drupal WordPress
you will see all the code that will
literally used to to build this site and
how does the site look well this is
Google platform we have a project very
aptly called our org and we can see here
everything that has been happening on
our site for the last few weeks actually
you can see everything that is happening
now we have an old log of everything
that people are doing from communication
standpoint and also that the automation
is doing itself so how is this running
this is running a kubernetes cluster in
this case cluster stats with with three
nodes and we have a node pool that
allows us to get scale from three to ten
depending on depending on load so if you
guys hated at the same time and lunch a
denial of service against us probably
this thing should be scary please don't
do that the Democrats will get to would
get from the other but we have some
storage associated with it and as you
guys can see we have we're creating a
volume based on NFS and attaching that
to the containers we can see also the
yamo at some point and then on the
workloads specifically we're running the
workload that runs the site itself the
PHP and Apache piece is a replication
controller somebody may be asking why
did you guys use a deployment which one
said that we wanted to make the whole
thing and to end will you start off form
for that and you may know that char form
is an open source project that runs with
providers so the kubernetes provided
that was available for terraform at the
time of when we set this up didn't
support deployments yet so we decided to
use a replication controller
about just a second what you're looking
at right here is actually the kubernetes
dashboard that's built into GCP so if
you're wondering to yourself well
kubernetes is fun to get running and
whatnot but then I have to run that
wonderful web UI and how do I run that
what does it look like this is actually
built into the console this will show
you not only the services that you have
deployed in this particular cluster but
any clusters that this project has
access to which is pretty darn cool so
you can see the memory that we're
currently using the CPU disk and a bunch
of other different metrics and you know
alerts and things like that mm-hmm
well we can also see that we have parts
here we have the different parts with
the containers or Ryan are things so we
have three containers here in that state
and it's one of those parts has two
things it has tetra papad and the Drupal
pub we can actually look into it and see
how the actual Drupal pod is getting
requests and getting stuff looks like
people are hitting it which is cool then
we have another pod which is called
cloud sequel proxy what cloud cycle
proxy does is actually adds as a secure
proxy between each one of the containers
and the database everything is encrypted
in the middle the database is completely
secured so the connection between the
containers and the database is fully
encrypted and proxied through this
container so what we do is we use it as
a sidecar to the main container so the
Drupal container things that the
database is in localhost is in 127 0 0 1
3 306 the proxies getting that securely
transporting that to the clot sequel
database what's interesting about that
is cloud sequel being a managed sequel
instance and a managed sequel service
for you for anyone to take advantage of
we don't want just sort of standard
authentication that people can take
advantage of or exploit or whatnot if
you remember back in those slides that
we had about managed security this is
one of the features that we want so we
want like better authentication in order
to be able to it establish a connection
to the backend and this allows you to do
that without your developers having to
understand any of that sort of thing
like Fernando mentioned they just think
that it's localhost running on what 3306
and then they're all set
deploying this in a sidecar fashion ends
up improving your ability to actually
leverage the platform
manage a lot of the complexity that's
that's involved with it but with still
it getting the advantages of being able
to not have things just exposed to the
rest of the Internet and and whatnot
correct so what else we have on the
services side of the coordinator
dashboard we can see basically the load
balancing / service discovery piece of
it we have two
- basically - thanks here we said we
have a service for those are kubernetes
fans this is a node Porter service
because that's what we used to connect
the Pingris and we also created an
ingress which instantiates a load
balancer and HTTP HTTPS load balancer in
this case we created a TLS certificate
with let's encrypt and we uploaded that
to Google plot load balancer so the
Google cloud load balancer controlled by
that ingress is doing all the TLS
processing for us and is completely
unloaded from uploaded from our our
containers what also we have here
obviously this eventually runs on VMs in
this case we decided to initially use
well these are the three instances our
kubernetes cluster you may notice that
we don't see the masters that's because
a control plane is handled by Google we
don't need to care about the masters we
don't need to care about making them
bigger or smaller Google we do that for
us we don't need to make it don't make
sure that the masters are up and they're
working the other thing that we have
here is an NFS server we went with the
poor - solution because first file store
was not releasable nomen we wrote this
software but now you can use cloud file
store and just create a managed version
of that the code that you will see in
the repo has an NFS server which is just
a simple via and we're working with the
open source community is particularly
people that are working on terraform to
make sure that that gets updated so you
can actually describe your files for
instance inside of terraform and then
get all of this stuff automated in the
future what's important to note though
is that that back-end whatever it
happens to be as long as it's read many
writes many it doesn't really matter
what it is it's modular it's kind of
plug in play and kubernetes doesn't care
you give it a persistent volume claim
and a persistent volume and you just say
make sure that those bits on those disks
are mounted in those containers and then
you're all set
yeah but again do you know philosophies
I don't want to be carrying about this
server if somebody does it for me it
keeps it up and running skills it up and
down for me and I just pay for what I
use much more than me making sure that
that NFS server is up that is been
patched with the latest and greatest
security that it won't reboot on a
Saturday 3m or something like that right
you can save 13 bucks a month if we
resize it though that's cool you could
save some money to Google we have our
name some external IP addresses the
other thing that we did is creating a
static IP address and linking that
static IP address to a load balancer so
that we can
pointed to the VNS and the other thing
that we did is also controlling the
entire DNS configuration of the site
from Google Cloud DNS so we can
configure it from there and we can
eventually create sub zones and at some
point we can put other sections we may
create an area for import another for
export and another for architecture at
some point the last piece that we have
here stackdriver
and stackdriver does all the monitoring
for us we didn't do a lot of work on
stack drivers so I'm sure you guys can
find stackdriver guys here with much
better dashboards than ours but what I
have is the simple update check so in my
welcome to cloud lamp this is not found
out anyway and we have some monitors and
and apparently my internet connection is
failing but that was pretty much it so
if you please check the site please
check the repo and and obviously the
idea with this is for us to build this
and learn as we go so we will basically
upload in we will be basically uploading
the site with all the things that we
find as we as we keep the site up
hopefully how are we going to be doing
the backups how are we going to be
creating policies ourselves to keep it
up and running hopefully at some point
we will connect it to the emails so
people can actually create usernames and
passwords and and and leave comments and
things like that that the other thing is
the code is up there if anyone is
interested in how do you use their form
to deploy this whole thing please feel
free to use it and since questions and
answers can you switch back over to the
slides cool
so like Fernando had mentioned it's on
there we go it's on cloud named cloud
lamp dot org if you actually go there
the first thing you can take a look at
is like the blog post that has a bunch
of things or you can notice on URL comm
slash cloud lamp which actually gets you
right over to the to the source repo and
you can take a look at some of the stuff
that we've got there just a disclaimer
as far as that goes this is a proof of
concept kind of thing like I was
mentioning earlier it is a it is our way
of our stuff it's our 20% project please
don't believe that this is sponsored by
somebody else this is Sebastian and
myself so if something looks like it's
coming from two days it's because it's
coming it's coming from two guys working
part time and also having a full time
job managing a bunch of lovely customers
also just just as a as a way of thinking
about it take a look at the repo and
then figure out like oh that's how they
did that I see why that components
interesting and then you can take that
concept and implement it in your own CI
CD sort of workflows we don't provide
any sort of CI CD tools as far as this
repo goes we do have some on our
platform but that's for another talk so
with that and that's it we have some
time for Q&A so thanks so much for
coming and for your attention and yep
[Applause]
[Music]